i went back and forth about whether to
cover this next story and i decided to
ultimately
and there's a few points i want to make
because there are kind of some bad takes
coming from this story so the story that
has surfaced is hey trump's finances are
collapsing well what's the evidence well
forbes has this writ a list of the
richest 400 americans that they publish
and donald trump is off the list for the
first time in a really really really
long time so donald trump's financial
situation is suffering the article on
forbes says donald trump is worth an
estimated 2.5 billion dollars
leaving him 400 million dollars short of
the cutoff to make this year's forbes
400 list of america's richest people the
real estate mogul is just as wealthy as
he was a year ago
when he was number 339 on the ranking
but he's down 600 million since the
start of the pandemic tech stocks
cryptos and other assets have thrived in
the covet era but big city properties
making up the bulk of trump's fortune
have languished knocking the former
president out of the nation's most
exclusive club
they have this chart showing trump's
ranking
in terms of uh wealth
and uh there was a point in the uh late
90s rather where trump was like roughly
in the top 100 wealthiest then in the
early 2000s he kind of got up close to
the 50th wealthiest and then it's been
declining since 2015. so there there's a
few different things here that i think
are important because there's there's
some confusion about sort of what this
means
we have to balance
on the one hand it really shouldn't be
insanely profitable to be president now
every president is gonna get at this
point they're gonna get a nice book deal
at minimum for sure
uh but remember that donald trump still
made 1.6 billion dollars over the four
years that he was president now he said
he was going to be out of his businesses
blind trust even though he didn't really
understand what that is the big
presentation with a stack of paper that
was legal paper that we don't even know
what what it did
he made a killing during his presidency
so did his children trump still made 1.6
billion during his four years
at the same time
the presidency
did some damage to trump's brand i mean
there's probably
close to half the country on principle
wouldn't go to a trump hotel at this
point in time and so trump's still
filthy rich
he's just not quite as rich relative to
this group of the richest americans
remember he's still as wealthy as he was
a year ago in terms of dollars but
because trump is real estate heavy and a
lot of these other rich people are more
diversified cryptos stocks other things
trump in ranking has fallen behind so
you you
a lot of people are wanting to take just
like a black and white view oh so well
if he's no longer in the richest 400
clearly he didn't rape and pillage for
his personal wealth while he was
president well no he benefited greatly
from being president foreign dignitaries
coming and staying at his hotels in
order to ingratiate themselves with him
etc
he still made 1.6 billion during his
presidency
his kids made a ton of money despite
being sort of loosely or less loosely
associated with the administration i
don't need the guy to be poor
but let's not allow him importantly
to skirt responsibility and the due
process of others because he's rich when
it comes to saying no this person
i don't have to testify in this case and
i don't have to provide documents in
that case and all this other stuff
because he used to be president or be or
because he was president at the time
and the issue of exactly how rich he is
relative to others is less important so
to some degree many of trump's
businesses are struggling trump makes a
ton of money from other things as well
licensing and different things
a lot of his hotels aren't doing so well
the value property values some have
suffered there's no doubt about that but
the right is pointing this and saying
you guys on the left were saying trump
was taking advantage of his position to
make money
and he didn't really make money no he
did he still made 1.6 billion it's just
relative to the other 400 richest
americans he comparatively fell slightly
behind 400 million a year while
president is your full-time job uh is
still very very solid now the other
question is
has he been honest about his wealth all
along
did he ever really have i think at one
point he was claiming three or four
billion
who the hell knows that's another
question altogether he's not an honest
guy that we know but let's not read more
into this than what we actually should
which is trump did extremely well while
being president even though he said it
was bad for him financially to be
president 1.6 billion is pretty good
but some other even richer mostly men
but people
um did even better than trump that's
fundamentally what it comes down to we
don't really need to read too much more
into it
one of our sponsors is curiosity stream
the only subscription streaming service
dedicated to documentaries if you're
like me you're always watching
documentaries you want to find the best
ones and curiosity stream is really a
must-have curiosity stream has a better
selection of documentaries than netflix
hulu or amazon i just finished watching
wasteland about a landfill
on the outskirts of rio in brazil
where
men and women sift through garbage
in order to try to make some money it's
horrifying but extraordinarily well done
they always have the newest and most
critically acclaimed titles when you're
looking for good documentaries use the
streaming service that specializes in
documentaries that's why i use
curiositystream they have documentaries
on politics economics history technology
psychology
everything if you love documentaries
you've got to have curiosity stream you
will see what i mean when you start
using it when you go to
curiositystream.com pacman you'll get 25
percent off a subscription which comes
out to just 15 bucks a year the link is
right underneath this video